muchas personas filas de espera y
confusión la confusión
de autobuses y carros salen hacia
diferentes puntos de ucrania y también
hacia polonia y otros países de la unión
europea
tengo miedo estoy estresada muy
preocupada quiero regresar
ellos vienen del oeste de ucrania
nuestros hijos están allá sin sus padres
que trabajan en quiebra así que
regresamos para estar con nuestros hijos
de todas formas no hay más trabajo aquí
porque nos quedaríamos
mi estado anímico está como el clima de
hoy cambiando sin embargo esos jóvenes
cambiaron de idea miren no podemos
marcharnos de aquí
de dónde viene somos de quien queríamos
irnos pero al final no nosotros nos
quedaremos los lugares escasean y las
personas están nerviosas la gran mayoría
de personas con las que hablé aquí no
tiene ni idea de que les deparará con
respecto a lo que ocurrió este juego